summer games done quick wrapped up last
week and it was made up of seven days of
back-to-back speedruns and raised over
1.2 million bucks for charity whilst the
whole week was super impressive here are
five of the best runs that you really
should go back and watch
the Octodad dadliest cats run is pretty
much guaranteed to make you feel bad
about your gaming prowess
luckily though you'll probably be too
perplexed to get too down on yourself
the runs commentary has a really great
balance between explaining the technical
elements and the story of the game while
also showing off some really clever
tricks tricks are hard Octodad is hard
sharing the limbs of one character
between two people is hard but seeing
all of these executed together is very
cool the two runners Jeff who
traditionally runs monkey ball and
misskaddykins work together really well
and complete the game in just under 20
minutes the cherry on top is getting to
see the final cutscene of Deadliest
Catch which is the serious treat if you
haven't seen it before if you love a
good speedrun race this year's Mega Man
4 face-off between Ullman City and
Shelley was a real nail-biter both
runners are wildly talented and
fortunately happen to be very evenly
matched which keeps the run exciting
right until the end where the winner and
loser are separated by near second the
runs stayed interesting thanks to the
great commentary and the different
routes each one it took that caused them
to diverge and meet up again at various
points this is one of the closest races
in games done quick history and if
you're a fan of skill-based retro runs
you'll definitely enjoy it the first run
of the marathon was a 100% Yoshi's
Island playthrough from trihex despite a
few mistakes tree hacks kicked off the
event extremely well by picking up every
star flower and coin in the game while
entertaining us for three hours with his
charismatic Fanta and a great rundown of
his techniques catering to both
experienced runners as well as the rest
of us his positive attitude set a great
tone for the week-long event as he
emphasized the community element of
speedrunning and the idea that it's
about collaboratively finding ways to
beat each game faster together and not
competing against each other one gutsy
runner took on the notoriously ant
Abell prince of persia sense of time and
it didn't go so well although that
doesn't mean it's not a great watch
Murphy's Law with the consistent factor
during this run that is everything that
could go wrong did go wrong even though
this run was riddled with crashes and
bad luck it's still fantastic thanks to
the unwavering optimism of Rana Hanako
who kept his spirits up through every
unfortunate occurrence
Hanako showcases a lot of cool tricks
like zipping past huge parts of the game
while wrestling camera angles and
occasionally an invisible Prince he does
a great job of explaining what's going
on and doesn't lose his cool through
multiple game crashes and setbacks if
you like watching speed runners compete
in fast paced 3d action platformers and
it's hard to go past 360 chrism and
gamerdomey bursting each other in super
mario 64 this anypercent race is riddled
with glitches exploit and skip focused
on wall speed 360chrism has a
particularly fortunate run and his
excitement when things go right is
infectious both runners pull off a
number of complicated tricks and chrism
even made history with the first ever
successful zero star run in a marathon
that involves picking up no stars
through the entire run which is a pretty
tough feat both runners clock in at
under 10 minutes so while it isn't a
long speedrun it's one of the most
technically impressive of the marathons
let me know down in the comments which
run from summer games done quick was
your favorite and which game do you like
to see played it's super fast I will
catch you again next week